your white male cisgender patriarchal
privilege is showing and your ignorance
of the complex nuances addressing your
microaggressions towards those our
lowest social classes social justice
warriors are at it again
not satisfied at making up entire new
words they've now found a way to quarrel
with the definition of actual words yes
now in the social justice warrior
lexicon words like thug riot and
terrorism no longer mean what they've
always meant this comes in the wake of
some cultural turmoil so after Baltimore
you've had plenty of pundits and people
on mainstream media who have declared
that the word thug is secret code for
the new n-word any of me right conmen
thieves degenerates lowlifes thugs
criminals
north pole them are fighting words
partner again it's not seem as some
friends belief in media but when we ask
people on the street when you think of
the word thug what do you think of I
think of somebody who is dis fortunate
trying to make it on their own those are
people that were there pants below their
waist
I think if Sonja's young a male probably
being given not a lot of chances I think
of a person trying to rob you some
people in the media have said that thug
is the new n-word would you agree
disagree anyone can be a thug thought
could be anybody
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
black person
I think thug is a term that is directed
toward a certain group but I think it
could be applied to anybody to me thug
is not very racially motivated but has
that connotation I think it's way more
sexist and racist I always I think male
before I think of any race thugs were
people that did criminal activity do you
think it's sexist toward males yeah I do
also I think your daughter's getting a
little antsy so I've heard the people
don't like the term criminal
because it's saying that its labeling
that's just stupid yeah I know they're
male and female and black privilege must
be showing it seems that people think
it's more racist to say that the word
thug is actually racist because in doing
so you're ascribing that to one
individual race of people this should be
an area where Americans are unifying and
agreeing the rioters in Baltimore were
thugs the bikers who shot each other out
in Waco we're thugs great we're all on
the same page now there is the point
that thug culture has only recently
become something seen as worthy of
emulation and of course some of that
stems from hip-hop culture which
ironically enough leftists have
informally declared it as the final say
on all things black culture now see I'm
from Detroit I don't even think of
hip-hop as the most defining aspect of
black culture I think of blues rock and
roll Motown gospel music all of which
have contributed grove greater
significance to a rich and storied black
american cultural history I think
leftists are saying it's racially
charged because the kind of gang culture
we're talking about isn't that of old
white biker gangs show me the 11 year
old kid looking like ZZ Top on a
three-piece rocker Plus granted for a
long time white gangs were super gay
it's the same thing when leftists get
mad and say oh if it's a brown person
you gotta say terrorist it's a white
person you won't know terrorism
ultimately has to have an ideological or
political end to its agenda shooting up
another biker and a glorified titty bar
doesn't count
which brings us to some of these twins
were leftists are furious that the media
isn't referring to the Waco shooting as
a riot and that's namely because it
wasn't an actual riot sure a shootout is
terrible unlawful and these people
should be fully prosecuted but nine dead
gang members is in a riot by the legally
recognized criminal act of inciting or
engaging in a riot
whereas in Baltimore were over 350
businesses who had nothing to do with
Freddie gray or the cops found
themselves vandalized or completely
destroy as part of what is essentially
the civil equivalent to a dirty bomb
riots indiscriminately caused chaos and
hurt people they don't care who and both
white people and black people throughout
American history have rioted and both
incidents involve what most Americans
would refer to as thugs just look at
this little experiment we did just yes
or no I want to show you pictures and
you're gonna say if you would think that
person is a thug okay okay no no
yes
no yes no now yeah No
No yes yes yeah okay
no yes I know people like yeah no no no
just looking at this picture you can say
thug no no okay yes no no
oh yes I'd say they're thugs I would say
they're thugs
yes
No yeah I think I'll give it a I feel
like the side you would say yes yeah
it's important to understand the PC
police right now we're trying to set up
language in a way that allows for the
open-ended twisting and contorting of
what's being said so that they can apply
a motive to the person using it without
actually ever proving anything so now
instead of talking about how to fix
problems with violence and cities in
America or how to curb biker shootouts
we're talking about whether thug is the
new n-word or a riot can apply to the
drunken neighbor down the street who's
yelling that he's Jesus versus the guy
who's actually trying to incite a riot
it D values the importance of language
it D values the importance of honest
debate and none of you have to accept
any of it and anyone who tells you that
you have to is just a bully lowlife
and/or thug you have me right conmen
thieves degenerates lowlifes thugs
criminals which you gave and think of
subscribing to this micro dressing
patriotic scope from the panty hey boy